we found out the hard way Arnold Palmer
is also trademarked wait yeah the drink
are his name the drink we got a cease
and desist letter from Arnold good I
guess that's how you know you've really
made it when Arnold Palmer's sends you a
cease and desist letter postmarked with
the cut to the man it's not from Arnold
Palmer himself is not a golfer
it's from the estate yeah I know they
license the name Arnold Palmer to
Arizona that's some deep [ __ ] so you so
critical your last name that's too close
to cream so I think you should go for it
you use you'd make a ice cream call to
cease and desist and then yeah you use
different you have that the art in two
places at different seasons and then you
change it for pretty cool to outlaw ice
cream just have pictures of different
gangsters of they're just white-collar
criminals Toth that's a bad as a song as
you move it's a Highland Park instead of
Logan Square this is solid ass plan that
might just work
[Music]
you
[Music]